Schmidlapp hamdullah peace be with you
welcome to the Dean show today we're
gonna be talking about a book like no
other book and this book when you live
by it you adhere to it cause you -
nothing but goodness cause you - the
purpose of life gives you peace
prosperity and you know what when you're
down and out and it just feels like this
life is just you know what it's taking
its toll on me and you're on the
antidepressants and you're suicidal but
why because you don't have purpose this
book illustrates explains lucidly the
purpose of life and gives you hope that
it's not just about this life there's
also a better life waiting and it
describes it in detail it's a miraculous
book you read all other kinds of books
this is the book that at the end of this
show
God willing you're gonna be excited to
go and read this book get this book the
Koran we'll be right back to talk about
the verbatim word of the crater that
happens in the earth the Koran here on
the deed show don't go anywhere
this is the beam you know this is the
this is the peace be with you Salaam
alaikum how you doing chef is it true
that you can get off the antidepressants
you can get off of all the
pharmaceuticals God willing and you know
because many people are depressed not a
great majority you know we're advancing
in technology but you know immorality is
on the rise depressions on the rise
suicides on the rise is this the
antidote to all of these things this
Quran definitely Intel by the will of
Allah because there's nothing better
than the words of the creator of the
heavens in yes that's the cure and we
challenge this is a challenge because
that's what says in the Quran well known
as Adomian call any man when she fell
metal in Malini we brought down in the
Quran what is cure and mercy to the
believers so accuse insha Allah by the
will of Allah all of our problems
how can people be sure now okay how
could they be sure that this Quran is
just not some other book that it's
indeed from the Creator because it's
sometimes it's hard to fathom and
imagine how would it God sit there
writing a book you know did it just drop
from the sky you know people start to
think like this and they're like you
know how is it possible right how can
they be sure God Allah subhanAllah they
spoke the Quran and the Quran was
revealed to the Prophet Mohammad Suleman
lies in them throughout 23 years and
it's a book that starts an end from
first chapter to the end and it's a
miraculous words of the creator the
heavens in the earth that the humanity
were challenged to bring the like of not
just the whole and this was yes
mentioned some verses but to bring the
like of one surah one chapter if it's
correct to say that but a sort of the
smallest word in the Quran can fits in
one line if they can bring up the like
of it if it's the work of human beings
then do that and nobody is there to even
to do that whatsoever
so miraculous words linguistically
what's the information what has been
mentioned there there are the different
orders the stories it's it's a
miraculous book from all sorts and means
and that's why we as as Muslims when we
call people to get to know what the
religion of Islam we call them to read
the Quran we don't have anything that we
hide there is no hidden agendas in our
religion we have our book this is the
book that we follow and please read it
right and if anybody is intimidated to
read a book and there's a something
something wrong them definitely read the
book because God a lost paradise is cool
in number and even come below I say o
Muhammad SAW Selim I warn you by the way
by the revelation from Allah so we need
all of us Muslims and non-muslims
everybody we need to really read the
Quran but for Muslims we have even more
rights that we have to observe to it so
I'd like to always make a contrast to
look at for instance because people
claim that the Bible is the inspired you
know Word of God that the authors were
inspired they started to write but many
academics people who were former
Christians you know I'm going to take it
to a clip right now as people can see
some places it looks like it's a
manipulation of the text where where the
author wants to change where the scribe
wants to change what the author said I
mean in many cases it may be that the
scribe thought this is what the author
really meant and so he changed it but
but sometimes the the text gets changed
to say just the opposite of what it
originally said and so that's that could
that can be a little bit troubling yeah
but as I engaged in historical research
on the Bible as I was getting my PhD in
New Testament studies at Princeton
Theological Seminary I started finding
mistakes in the Bible and this this cut
away at my assumptions that the Bible
was inerrant and then I started
questioning other parts of my faith is
Jesus really divine is a really a
Trinity now well this is an interesting
thing that the you know we think when we
read the Bible that we're we're
obviously reading the words that Matthew
wrote or that Paul wrote but the reality
is we don't have the originals of
Matthew or Paul's letters or of any of
the book of the New Testament or the Old
Testament
we had this this one of the leading
Bible scholars in the world today Bar
dr. bar Aaron he was a evangelical
Christian and he was born again and then
he went to Princeton got his his
doctorate and now he teaches and he says
that the Bible today we don't have a
copy of a copy of a copy of a copy of
anything original has been changed
scribes sometimes deliberately sometimes
you know intentionally sometimes you
know by mistake but basically they
changed a book so now thinking people
they're like hey if it happened to this
book it probably happened to the Quran
what do you got to say we believe that
the books we believe in all the books of
Allah the Torah the Bible these are
books from Allah words of the creator of
the heavens and the earth but humans
have been entrusted to save it but as
the fact with all human beings they
change and they do things in a corrupted
way so things has been changed it
doesn't mean that every single thing in
the Bible or in the Old Testament is
changed but you know many things have
been changed then the last final
messenger to all mankind which is the
Quran God Himself Allah the most high
promised that he would save the book and
nothing will be altered or changed in it
and that by itself is America fourteen
hundred years more than 1400 years ago
and the Quran with everything in letter
of it it's not like these funny people
they say they discovered on the ground a
transcript of the Quran Quran has been
saved not how you would find a book
under the ground the Quran has been
saved in the hearts of the people from
one generation to the other it's the
only bill buck on the face of Earth that
millions of people they have memorized
by heart
nobody even the Pope memorize the Bible
right but the Quran you'd find a child
seven eight nine ten years old memorized
the whole Quran memorization from the
beginning to the end and even his
language his mother tongue is not Arabic
but he has it memorized where is that in
the world you have a book written in
Arabic a totally foreign language to you
and he would memorize it word by word
over six hundred pages right memorize it
by heart and if somebody makes a mistake
he will correct him at any position that
he place
this bite suffers and recklessly we know
the book is not the the Quran the
verbatim Word of God is not a book of
science but it's a book of signs so
anyone who looks at it they'll see that
this is indeed a sign from the crater
and you old but you do have science in
there because many people fled religious
persecution because for instance the
Bible make a contrast we're not trying
to disparage on anybody but it's a fact
that you have unscientific statements in
there so scientists that were coming up
intellectuals is like hey this
contradicts science does this Islam does
the Quran do the same thing never
whatsoever why because it's from the
creator of the heavens in the earth so
the signs that are mentioned in the book
about some of the creation of Allah the
oceans the mountains and so on
it's our facts and that's why we have to
differentiate between what is theory
people had theories in the past and they
thought that this is so much certain and
true when they change it later on but
facts of life you would find it never
contradicting with what's in the Quran
and that's why this is there are many
things and mention the con about the
creation of Allah that people need to go
and to see for themselves that this
really fits the nature of what created
things and this people something didn't
know maybe 200 years ago this is truly
amazing I mean just if people would just
take the time out and be sincere and
look into it look into the purpose of
life does it does it clearly explain the
purpose of life in this book is it a
believable message because people also
go away from from following many of
these man-made religions because it just
don't make sense right call an freeze
you as a human being from being enslaved
to others slave to another human being
slave to your desires and slave to the
the pressure of the world that we live
in frees you from all of that and makes
you a real servant to the creator of the
heavens and yet call you to worship none
but the creator of the heavens and the
earth alone rely with your heart on him
he's the one that you turn to whenever
you are in need of anything you know
he's the one that you were that you
worship right and you you look things in
the right perspective and he's the most
twice that means he created for traitors
were a purpose and then this life is
nothing but a test and after this life
is the UFT
people will be either engender paradise
or the Hellfire so it sets the go
for the human being in everything that
they do very clearly everybody can
understand very clear very lucid very
understand the world pragmatics makes
sense we'll be right back with more
talking about the verbatim Word of God
the Quran pick it up read it right back
here on the Dean show
back here on the Dean show talking about
the verbatim Word of God at the Koran
this is not a book of just fairytales
something that Muhammad concocted this
is indeed from the crater anyone takes a
look analytical scientific approach they
examine it they'll conclude that it is
indeed from the crater we contrast it to
the Bible which we don't have a copy of
a copy of anything original obviously
and many Christians don't know this but
I'll say if they look at it you know and
they research they'll see that this is
you know indeed something that can't be
from the crater one mistake
there's one mistake it can't be from the
crater is that right that's correct and
it's miraculous in nature and when a
person wants to read the Quran Oh read
it with an open heart and oh and read it
realizing that we're human beings were
created by the creator of the heavens in
the earth and you would see clearly how
the message is from the Creator that
fits the nature of every human being
very simple very easy and to do what is
right and to stay away from what is evil
he created evil and good things for a
reason you would never be able to see
what is right unless there is some
things that are wrong this is the nature
of this life because it's a test in
itself so you would find the wisdom of
the creator of the heavens in the earth
being explained and with the stories of
the messengers and and the struggle
between the truth and falsehood and what
happens to the people of the truth what
happens to the people of falsehood so
it's definitely a great thing it's a
waste of life when a person doesn't read
the book of Allah tell us we mentioned
the there's prophecies in this Quran no
mistakes
there's no contradictions you mentioned
some of the science and the Quran
Mountains and and the development of the
human being isn't it true that when the
Muslims those who have submitted to the
will of God when they were they were
living by this crown that you know they
were like the superpower of the world is
this true that's true they were they
were the advancement of society usually
people when they think of those who hold
fast to religion they become backward
and they live the dark ages because it's
all fairy tales and things that is
against what facts and science and what
life of the people is in Islam it's the
total opposite where Muslims stayed away
from or turned away from the whole
it's teachings and so on they became
backward and they became humiliated and
so on so when people they they hold fast
to the Book of Allah they were superior
in the light and that their whole entire
life changed tail
for example the atoms they were just
nomads and they're everywhere and they
were awaited by everybody but when they
hold fast to the Quran they let the
whole world so why because the Quran
actually gives you the the purpose of
your life that everything will make
sense people they suffer when it comes
to matters of the religion because they
have been taught that religion and money
or your success in this life they go
against one another either all or Islam
it's not the way you'll be more
successful in this life you'll be happy
we have wife children work successful
all of this but all of that makes sense
that because it's all from the creator
and heavens in earth and you'll be
taught how to be a father how to be a
husband how to be a son how to be a
worker how to be someone leading others
so it keeps you in your occupations you
don't have to be one thing or the other
you can stay in your occupation but to
be the best human being in whatever
occupation you have we'll teach you that
some people might think that because a
lot of the false propaganda that the
Quran is a book of violence would you
say this this is absolutely a wrong
statement anybody can claim anything and
that's why the book is there we're not
hiding anything from the book we don't
have another chapters that we hide it
was as Muslims that we dark rooms we
open and read it the book is out there
and it's memorized by millions of people
read it and see what the Koran says and
don't take things out of context because
yes as a part of life there is violence
on the face of it and regulates this it
makes you see what's happening in the
world and how things to be how to react
with all of what's happening some people
they get caught up how can this world be
a perfect world but it's all so much
evil and killings and atrocities and so
on it meant to be this way because God
wants from us to worship Him in
different levels of worship to worship
Him with patience to worship Him with
struggle to worship Him was loved with
fear with hope to be or fulfilling all
these means with means of worship so
when you would see in the Quran that
when people think
religion that when you apply the
religion you would find our buddy
everybody is good and the earth is just
the birds and it's not like this right
this is a life that it's a test in
itself but she will be happy in the
midst of all of this you understand why
things are happening the way it's
happened different levels of worship
worship is not just to to sit and do
some rituals it's more than just rituals
it's everything in your life it's the
the time of struggle
it's the calamities it's the good things
and so on and that's why people they run
away from religion right because they
think religion is just an ideal world
that doesn't exist no this is the
reality of this life and that's what the
Quran will teach you that you can be
extremely happy and enjoy in the midst
of all of these craziness because really
the place of it is in your heart and you
would understand there's a reason for
this there's the purpose of this so my
position to be living and to be kind to
others when they're not and so on and so
forth well knowing that there's a reason
the wisdom behind it and how to egg been
in the midst of all of this it's all in
the Quran and in the way of the prophets
of message what are some of the benefits
to memorizing the Quran and then
obviously we talked about you know the
the miraculous nature of the Quran so
those who who live by Islam now they
they profess to be those who have
submitted to the will of God the same
profession that Jesus made he was a
Muslim you worship only the Creator and
they lived by his loss and they said oh
well oh god now you're a Muslim but we
see the Quran has been abandoned it's on
the Shelf collecting dust when it comes
down maybe for a Ramadan or when someone
dies you see a lot of this happen right
and this is a very sad thing there's a
habit of the alarm that was supposed to
follow their way the Companions of the
Prophet SAW said Allah Quran was not
just a book that they seek some
blessings from it once in a while Quran
was their life they learned the Quran to
live the life according to the Quran
abdullah al masud and the ones that came
after him one of the taping on at the
second generation he said we took the
Quran from the Companions of the lower
Arnhem in such a way ten verses at a
time we would recite them learn the
rulings of them and act according to
them and
we'll go to the next set of 10 verses
this is how the Koran was in their life
and where is there in our life we and
actually I would take this opportunity
and call myself and everyone take the
Quran seriously learn the Koran said
verses after center versus learn it of
course from the right sources memorize
the Quran and don't say I'm too old it's
only for the children repeat the verses
over and over again even if it's awarded
a verse a day that you would repeat all
the time 15 minutes half an hour but
never give up whatsoever and learning
the meaning of it and while you're
learning the meanings how am I gonna act
according to what this verse means and
this is how the Quran will change our
life and wallah he by the will of Allah
your life will be totally such a happy
contentment peace by just constantly
reading and pondering and reflecting and
acting according to the word of Allah
the word of the creator of heavens and
earth what a waste
when people are just talking and talking
and reading but neglecting the words of
the Creator the heavens and the earth
and not learning it from the beginning
to the end even if it takes 10 years 20
years even a person dies before that
intentions goes beyond one's actions but
to start today and every day there's no
day passes unless you open the Quran you
read something in it you repeat and you
memorize even one word of it you reflect
upon some verses in it and you would
think to yourself did I act according to
this today or not and tomorrow and after
tomorrow and this is how we transform
ourselves to be the people that are lost
final time I want an earth to receive
the ultimate joy in this time in the air
we're gonna take a break we'll come back
with more here tell about the verbatim
Word of God the Quran pick it up read it
live by it understand it implement it
we'll be right back with more here on
the Deen show I want you to imagine you
wake up and in front of you are a bunch
of guys running around kicking a ball no
goals no lines no rules what would you
think but is that your life surely every
sport has its goal every game has its
end it has its objective it has its
rules how about life how about our life
isn't there a goal
to life isn't there a purpose an
objective that we have to reach we think
so the Koran tells us that we exist in
order to worship God and worshiping God
means knowing God as the Quran says when
the holocrons inner will insert lle
ibadah worship though is not some narrow
small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal back here on the Dean
shown we're talking about the verbatim
word of god the curt and now there's a
statement that was made by the last
photo mr. problem Hamid can you comment
on this
I'm gonna practice my Arabic a little
bit you correct me and get some good
practice now I look at a lake can you
define this and tell us what this
actually means al Quran The Book of
Allah o jetan Hodja means and evidence
established without any doubt whatsoever
either for you or against you
so when you say Hodja that means if I
tell you the evidence or something it
would not leave you with any doubts
something very strong something so
profound that you won't be able to have
any doubt whatsoever so this is what the
Hodja means so the Quran is Hodja the
Quran mix the reciter the Quran would be
a part of how strong the evidences and
the clear statements are mentioned very
precise no ambiguity no unclear things
and then it says either for you or
against you meaning when you read the
Quran now you would find for yourself
you would find yourself
I won't say force but by a necessity you
have to believe in this is very clear
otherwise it becomes against you in the
day of resurrection because why didn't
you follow the truth the truth has
characteristics to it one of which once
you see it once you read it it becomes
very clear
to you that this is the truth but take
away the arrogance take away the
diseases in the heart ways of the
forefathers the pressure of whatever
right these things are negative evil
things so but we are being tested with
regard to our hearts that is this is
something that we believe is the truth
or not otherwise they would come in the
day of judgment it'll be the reason for
people to enter the Hellfire you read
the Koran you get to know the truth why
did you follow it why don't you apply it
in your life and the same thing if you
are Muslim where are you from the Koran
orders of Allah lost parallel to Allah
orders to do certain things who bathe us
from something and we know that for sure
and this is the words of Allah why he
turned away from okay can we apply this
Shaikh now that we see today we have the
cyber bubble and there's a lot of good
that could be accomplished you know if
we use a lot of these things Facebook
Twitter you know and the media to go
ahead and to help deliver the purpose of
life and to share the true for the
people but now if you are let's say one
who submitted to the world out of Muslim
and you find yourself on you know
following many of the Facebook and the
internet and now if you add up your time
for instant at the end of the day and
you spent here let's say three hours a
lot of is useless time you know gossip
and you know just nonsense but over here
your dedication to the Quran is almost
zero is that that proof that's gonna be
against you now you had time for useless
chitchat or gbj but over here you even
put five minutes in is that a problem
definitely it's a problem and that's why
especially in the world that we live in
you have to set a time for you to read
the Quran and to ponder over it pick the
most the best time of your day the way
you can focus and so on and again it
doesn't have to be an hour can be 15
minutes but with dedication with
sincerity right and whatever you read
understand it even try to memorize it
repeat it a lot and get to know the
meanings of it and apply it in your life
and take the meta step-by-step not on
your own of course we need to learn from
the people of knowledge and so on
especially if its rulings this is
permissible is not permissible but most
of the Quran is about things that we can
relate to creation of Allah calling us
to worship Him alone to put our trust in
him to have
what is the meanings of like what is the
ways of allah on earth so that we would
see things coming ahead and how to be
steadfast now when you don't when it
doesn't make sense for you now but you
know what's coming ahead and things like
this so we can relate to most of the
quran like that rulings hell harem and
permissive and not permissible yes we
need to as the people of knowledge and
so on but definitely the call is for
everyone and i hope this is can find
really somebody that would have the
proper way of listening to this
we need to recite every day even if it's
ten minutes you have to you should try
to memorize every day the best your
ability every day even for for ten
minutes and most importantly to act
according to the quran so that when
you're reading the quran okay i'm
applying all of this in my life I mean
that's there is no waste of time
learning the Quran is there over here
you're wasting time and probably picking
up a lot of bad deeds seeing things you
shouldn't see but is there any time if
you spent just five minutes ten minutes
at any time even if you struggled with
it definitely not and I would tell you
something that makes it easier if you
think and try this and you would find it
true if anytime you would leave the
width or the portion of the Quran that
you read every day because you're busy
with something you would never fulfill
that you are busy what were you busy
with never the Quran never take you away
from fulfilling the things that you need
to do a day a day every day one of the
early generations understand he said I
start reciting the Quran and every time
I recited the Quran I found that my time
is more blessed and I can do more things
and I kept increasing increasing till I
recite ten juice a day that means he
finished the Quran every three days and
a lost island Allah blessed his day so
much that he can do even more in it
these are the things that will be
amazing that she cannot really write it
with the pen and paper this is something
that you would see in your life but be
truthful and give the time to the Quran
no matter how much time you give to the
Quran you would find the blessings and
the rest of the day that Allah will
bless your relationship your life your
everything getting the family together
and to get them to read the Quran and to
understand the Quran and if you can't
read if it's difficult for you the
difficulties that you go through give
you double of the reward
the Prophet SAW selim this is the mercy
of Allah this is what he said that the
one that recites the Quran a Tartar fear
attack time meaning that like you're
doing like this you're not able to to
read fluently you got 2 e words when we
work for the recitation one letter is
with 10 rewards is better than the
reward or whatever it contains and one
reward is for the struggle that you go
through till you reach the level where
you can fluent to your site at you we
look with the scribes with the angels
amazing this is d the truth you've
beautifully played it and hopefully we
can implement it in our lives and be
successful in this life in the next
I mean thank you very much very slowly
so some tips here for you really
important it behooves you to read this
book to live by this book it was sent as
guidance for the whole of mankind if
it's your first time tuning in and you
got to hear about the Quran go ahead and
you can call us 1-866-376-8255 a turf or
guidance and start to do some homework
homework some late work you know because
the people who have power money and fame
they still can't find contentment
because peace is something you can't buy
you can't buy a six-pack of peace peace
and contentment prosperity comes from
living the purpose of life and that
purpose comes from the creator of life
so call us
book and visit us here every week at the
Dean show we'll see you next time God
will until that peace be with you